they would um post the grades
at the bulletin like outside the certain
building designated buildings
and i just remember like looking for my
name and i was like
i'll be looking and then i would see the
f and i would just start crying
what's up everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast
we have a very special guest it's
actually a guest that you guys have been
asking for
really no [ __ ] that's what's up yes
thank you
[ __ ] weeby thank you thank you
it's good
here bro when you uh texted me i put
your name as your actual name steve lee
yeah and when it popped up i was like yo
who the [ __ ] is this
thanks [ __ ] is
oh that's way different well because i
know you okay it's
steve is different than a stevie well i
know another steve lee and i'm like
a [ __ ] steve lee you [ __ ] ship seki
like that would be like
pete but his the real alien says pee wee
oh it's peewee i thought it was like
some random steve lee from my church
from like back in the day
i'm like i only know like a couple of
steve lee's asking for editing work or
something i was like
well it's because like you know people
come out of the woodwork sometimes
like oh do they do that to you now
because you're you're six come on man
you're successful you're doing your
thing man let me tell you like so i had
a dude that hit me up i hadn't talked to
this guy
in [ __ ] years right and the last time
i talked to him yeah i almost whooped
his ass
like what did he do it was so it was
edited hey i was wondering if you want
to do a business venture
um you know i just need 800 000 i got a
donut shop
i wanted to do right there on the corner
it's a cambodian donut shop
so he hit me up and he's like hey bro
how have you been i didn't know who the
[ __ ] it was
yeah and i text him back i'm like
question question mark who the [ __ ] is
this
right he's like oh it's me blah blah
blah i'm not gonna say his name from
junior high school
and he's like yo bro like i live in
seattle now and i'm actually getting
married and everybody's
your adventurer has business ventures
written all over it it's not even a
business manager he was his friend
he was asking me to marry him him and
his wife
wow because he found out that i was an
ordained minister and i
and i married a couple of my friends all
right that's kind of blue i wasn't
expecting that well that's what i'm
saying
that's way out of left from left field
number one i don't even [ __ ] like
weddings like number two
yeah wants who likes weddings and i
messaged him back i'm like bro
who the [ __ ] are you oh you see you
that's why i've always admired you you
you know you cut to the chase i don't
have time for this yeah you don't give a
[ __ ] about him
yeah but you said who the [ __ ] are you
yeah i was like doug i haven't
i was like i haven't talked to you in
years yeah and on top of that the last
time we talked i almost beat your ass
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
right yeah yeah right he was like oh man
like there's no disrespect and i was
like no disrespect dude i don't even
know who the
like it's been so long i don't even have
your number in my phone it's like
he's expecting you to be the priest of
the [ __ ] wedding it's like you have
to
marry him and his wife is to be well his
wife now i don't i've never even met her
wow you know what i mean i haven't
talked about according to him you guys
have history you and the wife
like we're tight because we went to the
same church fifth grade yeah
some weird [ __ ] so when i saw you and i
was like who the [ __ ]
when did you when did you when did it
register oh it's
it's steve when i read it i was like
steve i was like
i had to sit there for for a little bit
and then you said
you had that footage i read it again it
said album i'm like oh this is stevie
[Laughter]
but you have but you have an album
coming out yeah oh dude you went right
to he went right to what like i thought
we could do this at the end
no no no no no i want to talk about the
peacocks in your name
we'll get to that peacocks everywhere i
only found out that you
uh rapped not too long ago and i
actually found out through dumb
yeah i [ __ ] you know like again like
you know i'm not from l.a or anything
but i
i did i've always been a fan of the the
culture you know the art and i've always
looked at it as
you know art form you know similar to
like the way
[ __ ] painters do their [ __ ] you know
and i've always and like
like my kind of um knowledge came from
like
just watching yo mtv raps yeah at first
yeah
you know every day at 4 30 and then you
know dr dre and lover you'll be like
you know and then and then it's not like
it wasn't even your traditional like rap
groups it was the things that caught my
eye
i were like the weird groups like what
what's
dell like who's down yeah i'm like oh
this is really tight you know
or who's the boogie monsters or who's
the far side you know or cyprus hill
okay that's
probably a better example and then i was
obsessed with them and then like
through years i mean it was it's been a
definite progression where
i'm a fan first i'm a fan i just i love
the
90s [ __ ] you know and then but then when
i went to asu
it was first when i saw the far side i
saw the far side like in high school my
homie had a
suzuki samurai it was maybe even a
school night he goes hey there's this
group
performing at the distillery in
escondido i'm like whoo
i remember walking to that club it was a
little dinky club
i'm like what far what is this and i
just remember seeing the stickers
it was like the with the dog with the
fire hydrant you know the black and
yellow stick
it's like the traditional far side
sticker and then i remember this
kid walking by before the show started
like far side in the house or
said something like oh this they have a
fan base i knew that
yeah i didn't say fan base back then i
don't think people said [ __ ] like that
oh they have a fan base but in my mind
i'm like oh well
people know about these guys but they
had those fan clubs like back and they
would they would uh
they would connect online and they would
do meetups and [ __ ] yeah this was like
91.
like this is before like they even
dropped bizarre right to the far side
okay okay so it was like they've just
got either just got
signed or about to get something before
they even release their house oh you
were like at the inception
the conception where and boy let me tell
you
that performance really rocked my world
like i mean they were wearing vans like
a caballero you know they're doing
sit-ups on stage and it was like it was
like so bizarre
like it was bizarre but really
impressive like
fat lip had a shirt off they're you know
doing weird [ __ ] pop locking moves
and
routines and i'm like okay i i
i love this [ __ ] and so that's
part of my rearing where i like just
experiencing that
i went to a concert in um 89
it was the sugar cubes public image
limited
but then de la soul oh [ __ ] de la soul
was also on the roster
of this festival or a concert i was in
eighth grade
so i'm like oh and that's when
i fell in love with them and i bought
three feet high and rising
so i'm just giving you kind of like a
history of like how i discovered it and
like
you know shocking enough my brother was
always like a punk rock or indie rock
dude
you know he had bob marley posters well
that's what i'm saying like this is the
weird thing right because you and your
brothers
in music is way different way different
but but people don't realize it's way
different but i learned because i used
to um have you seen the movie mid 90s
no oh it pays homage to like 90s
skateboarding but
there's a scene where they have the same
dynamic older brother young brother
older brother would leave and the young
brother would go into his room and like
go through a cd collection
like i did that with my bob like he
wouldn't be home and i would sneak in
his room
and i would go through his record
collection dude he would have
like i learned about echo and the
bunnymen
and like black flag to bob marley to
depeche mode
to like the cure and stuff like your
brother like listens to white boy
depression music
according to him it's math rock okay
what the
[ __ ] is that i know i'm [ __ ] talking
about i know
so it's like he he schooled me one one
night he's like
i go what is this it's math rock dude
no it's not that it's [ __ ] it's math
rock dude
math rock it's like what
so math rock i guess it's indie
rock kind of like punk rock but it's
it's technical
it's technical so the chord progressions
are math
like you know what i mean like like
really intricate
does he play instruments you know dude
believe it or not
i don't know if he's gonna get mad at
this but
he was in a like a hippie band like get
the [ __ ] out of here
really it was the name of the band
was called a laxed in superb
and and then if you look that up
it's it's named after an apple
there's footage out on the internet of
them performing really
yeah dude he's got long james e haw hair
dude
and he's like waving it around like dude
dude i'm not i'm not lying at all
it's out there the evidence is out there
dude so he was okay
you said so he had this keyboard
he begged my mom to buy it for him
and so he was working at some coffee
shop in la jolla
if he got swindled before what are you
doing
[ __ ] panicking in the approached him
like he's a record producer
or something and he said here you can
put on my keyboard
and dude it was like a two thousand
dollar keyboard
yeah dude so i'm telling you my
brother's got piano
skills galore really yeah dude
he could play but he was dude i don't
know
at a coffee shop just comes up to him no
it wasn't random there was some guy he
knew but
this guy was like a talker okay he
probably frequented
like the coffee shop like a lot of
keyboard
and he just no no no it wasn't like that
it was more like
unlike kind of like staking it out
yeah yeah yeah yeah grooming him per se
if i if i lost a 2 000 keyboard that my
parents got me at the time i would have
been
dead oh yeah i think my parents would
have beat the [ __ ] blood videos
um you know this is going back to even
like growing up in a korean household
yeah
i remember one night dude like he had
just gone out of rehab or relapsed on
what whatever and uh you know you know
korean fathers yeah they're like hella
temperamental mm-hmm
highly abusive to say the least oh yeah
highly abusive in hindsight you know i
had to
talk uh to my therapist about all this
stuff
yeah yeah yeah just trying to
go through it and just work through
these things well because we're both
korean too and we kind of just accept it
as fact
and we don't really think about you know
the future repercussions that we have so
we didn't realize
oh well why white people don't do that
it's not like
this at the oliver's it's it's different
there
i could i see his dad hugging him yeah i
love you sorry
about positive affirmations not our dads
yeah but so anyway it was
at night time and we had like a long
hallway this is our house in power
a long hallway and like our bedrooms
around the hallway hit
the master bedroom there my omanappas
were at the end
yeah and then i hear commotion in the
hallway
like not commotion but like boom boom
like
and i [ __ ] i just squeaked open my
door they were doing
gently jackie chan versus gently like
kung fu they were fighting each other
yeah and so but the one thing that stood
out
is damn bob fought back
he was doing he was doing like you know
he's trying to get double leg takedowns
and he was like
backing him up it was like a back and
forth mutual
like aggressive exchange between father
and son
wow and so i'll you can only imagine me
like
just peeping this out like just through
a crack of my
my door yeah so i'm sorry it's gonna be
something
it's crazy too because like there's a
moment where you you kind of realize
that
you know you could probably size up your
day
well my dad's like five foot four i'm
sick
i'm not sorry i'm six what i'm sorry
yeah it sounds just about right yeah
that sounds perfectly correct
you don't have to tell me twice i'm
laughing but i'm like wait a minute
that's normal yeah i'm a lot bigger than
my dad right
and so like even for me too but you know
i think because they beat your ass so
much when you're younger you can't
to get that psychological switch of i
could stop you if i want to
yeah it takes a bit of time oh yeah yeah
yeah because i was bigger than
bigger than him when i was in the eighth
grade right
right right right but you know for him
like i remember
i remember when i went to college and
people were like they would talk about
their parents and be like oh remember
back and then we used to get spanked i'm
like
even back in the day my dad beat my ass
yesterday the [ __ ] spanking they use
weapons and [ __ ]
like belts and [ __ ] i told the story on
the podcast before where
when i was a kid in elementary school i
specifically remember the [ __ ] because
i was a class clown i used to make jokes
right right right but if you're a class
clown you obviously get in trouble
and it was this i remember the specific
joke that i made it was in fourth grade
back then elementary school elementary
school and so i made this stupid little
joke where the teacher was doing an
exercise where she wanted to use
visualization and she was like i was
like i can't do it because i don't have
a camera in my head so i can't take a
picture
yeah so you know that made the kids
laugh and she goes i'm calling your
parents and i went
[ __ ] oh yeah she could she doesn't know
what happens when you call my parents
it's not like they come over and i get
reprimanded you know with the slap on
the wrist i'm not gonna get my ass back
this is a different they don't realize
you're dealing with a whole different
planet
exactly like consequences this is a
different thing and so my dad comes over
and then she starts explaining how i'm
disruptive in class i make a lot of
jokes and my dad is just kind of smiling
now
you shame the family and then in my ear
he's whispering to me in korean see what
happens when you cut it home
when you get home you're dead yeah
you're dead you just said that
yeah and so i'm crying but the teacher
doesn't know she's like your father is
very pleasant oh no
no no you don't know what the [ __ ] he's
saying to me right now so i
we get home and you know my dad is just
speeding on the way back home because
he's [ __ ] pissed
right he always drives like a thousand
miles per hour when he's mad
we get home he goes the one's like get
going first
you go in first right so i open the door
right
and i'm sorry i'm sorry okay i just had
a visual dude this is ptsd yeah oh
please
so i i go inside right and it's just
dead quiet yeah and he tells me to go
into the living room oh yeah
and then it's just dead quiet i turn
around i [ __ ]
turn around and a [ __ ] office chair
is flying at my head oh yeah oh yeah
that sounds right
wow in the head and then my dad starts
like ww stopping me on the floor
yeah i got one for you i got another one
so i'm in a fifth sixth grade
i have the new casio first ever sampling
keyboard
okay where you could press the button go
hey
and then the lower actives you're the
freddie groomer keyboard
it's me and my white friend david oliver
laying you know he's on the bed we're
[ __ ]
around with it it was my dad was taking
a nap
oh [ __ ] he was taking a nap he's got
like three
clothing store he's tired
dude he [ __ ] bum rushes in the room
butt naked yes yeah and
he [ __ ] pulls the keyboard
out of the socket and uses it as like
thor's [ __ ] hammer
on my back like he's he uses boom
but who is beating my heart of your in
front of me david although i have to
probably traumatize him to this day
they traumatized him i mean
yeah and so he's a [ __ ] you know i'm
crying oh
yeah dad i'm sorry you know dude that's
not the traumatic part
so he beats my ass i'm [ __ ] i don't
know he
i felt like he broke my back
he's leaving the room and i
i look it you know i see his [ __ ] ass
there's [ __ ] tissue paper sticking
out of his ass dude
no no it's like [ __ ] like like
not even it was like stringy
it was like a tampon you don't like the
string
so that's what like i remember from this
traumatic event like
damn my dad's [ __ ] is like moisture
he got like a moist you got he got like
a wet butthole or something like that
yeah that's like some korean remedy like
wait it was like
i don't know i didn't ask yeah why would
you
you just have to get another beating for
asking like hey dare why do you have
tissue paper
sticking out of your ass you don't even
ask when you're 18.
yeah or even 25 just except 35 or
85 years old you've never asked that's
just something
yeah that's some other [ __ ]
why is he naked that's a good question
i'm like i'm trying to figure out why he
thought it was appropriate
the show has a different to another
[ __ ] white kid named david oliver
pretty good question i guess the only
thing i could think of you're putting me
on the spot
maybe in like where he's from busan i
don't know
maybe in the his korean village or
whatever yeah that's the way they did it
in their i don't know
what the [ __ ] i know butt naked dude was
he butt naked all the time
that's also a good question like in the
house like his name no no
no but that day he was the day
that david oliver came over dude imagine
what that would do
if you're like a white kid what if like
i mean imagine what he would think of
korean families after that like
oh this is how they do it in their
household did he come over again after
that i don't think so for a long time
i would get so jealous i'd go to their
house and like i said like
man this kid had it all he had like an
aquarium like with lizards he had like a
nice bookshelf he had like oh
you know not to say like we had a good
upbringing but like the way his father
embraced him i was so [ __ ] jealous
like he would walk down the steps
and he would hug him in front of you in
front of me he'd go
son i love you you know i love you so
much son
my you're always welcome you're always
welcome here as well stephen you know
he would they would say [ __ ] like that
there's a [ __ ] violin playing in the
back
dude i'm telling you they had avocado
like we would make guacamole
i'm not bullshitting you back then
that's how i learned how to make
guacamole
because as a child from david from david
oliver the oliver's because
every [ __ ] time he'd be he'd be like
hey you want to
he would just get into it and i remember
one ingredient they used i still [ __ ]
you know they'd use miss mrs dash uh
lemon herb
yeah yeah yeah seasoning on it and i
that always caught my eye i'm like oh
they use
it that was the white people saw the
time people
yeah i remember this is dash lemon herb
yeah yeah all the time
what in the [ __ ] you're crazy you're was
your dad your dad seems a little
more violent than other korean dads
though yeah like
my dad definitely didn't come in with
tissue paper out of his [ __ ]
as he beats me in front of this white
kid named david no it was
let me tell you something you i'm glad
you brought it up and you know rest in
peace pops rest in peace
but uh there was a time where i learned
this like in my 30s where
you know how koreans and then like only
koreans will know this
the the whole keeping secrets yeah yeah
yeah yeah do you know what i'm talking
about i don't have to tell you twice
yeah right
so there's that obviously in my family
but
to the point where well dad knocked
mom's tooth out
that's how she got that fake tooth damn
yeah
and then i'm trying to work through this
and my brother
my brother is involved too he's like
dude i thought you knew i'm like
no [ __ ] i didn't know that yeah
yeah
what the [ __ ] he's like oh i thought you
knew you don't remember that day we had
to
take the dresser and put it in front of
the door and mom's bleeding
there's blood coming out of my mom's
mouth i'm like
i think this is what happened as a child
as a child it was so traumatic like
i like blocked that out because i was i
was like kind of remembering
like glimpses of it or like the feeling
and i do remember
like even when we lived in minnesota and
[ __ ] of like my mom like
barricading doors and [ __ ] yeah my dad
was a monster
he was your monster back then your mom
stayed with him throughout the whole
thing
well this is going back to the korean
yeah there's a there's a stigma too of
like there's a stigma of
even when the dude knocks you the man
knocks your tooth out you stay you know
what i mean yeah yeah it's [ __ ] crazy
that's [ __ ] nuts that's [ __ ] nice
my parents definitely
had like crazy crazy fights and it's
funny too because my mom thinks that
even when i was younger that i wouldn't
remember these things but i remember
like we were talking on the phone not
too long ago
and uh i was telling her about a couple
of my other friends who were going
through marital issues right and i was
asking her advice because i'm not
married
i was like they're asking me you know
for advice and you know do you have any
wisdom to impart
and i kind of told them about the
situation and my mom was like well their
relationship's all [ __ ] up why are
they even together i was like well
hold on you [ __ ] freak hold on a
second i was like do you remember when
you
when i was like eight years old you
threw a fully loaded rice cooker at our
dad's head
and she goes you remember that oh like
that's the thing and so you can't just
erase this [ __ ] i was like yes i
remember there was rice everywhere
oh there's rice in the cooker i had to
clean it like yeah of course i remember
this yeah and i said
at the house you you missed his head a
little bit yeah
and then it cracked the tile and that
missing chunk is still there from when
you do the rice cooker she goes
you have really good memory oh yeah
that's what she said
yeah i remember that [ __ ] you [ __ ]
psychopath yeah korean parents are weird
they got
this also that some of them could be a
bit racist as far as like
who they want you to be with too you
know my parents it can't just be any
asians
it's gotta be south korean hanguksar
you know what's happening like my
parents weren't so
they weren't so concerned about the race
part they were concerned about them
our kids not being able to speak korean
so they were okay with me being with
another
ethnicity but they had to learn know how
to speak korean what you're you're a
girl
yeah wow yeah my parents were okay well
my dad's a pastor
oh so like you know he has he doesn't
give a [ __ ] you know it's just more like
i don't want
your kids not to know our culture right
right right
right right right although white people
he was a little bit like
yeah i don't know yeah yeah because he
had like the stigma of like if you get
with the white girl they're going to
leave you
yeah so your title was the man he was he
was like
the little dude the at the korean church
the pastor yeah at the korean church
yeah so he was uh he was a deacon at the
the church that we grew up in and then
he started his own church he opened up
his own church so he had first dibs on
the donuts and all that [ __ ]
all that other [ __ ] dude he got the best
coffee the pasta belly was coming out
because everybody would give them food
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah that korean church that
was another kind of
experience where dude is so weird i just
knew
like the smell of the church and [ __ ]
like i just knew after
everyone leaves i get donuts rachel's
all korean churches smell the same
yeah there's a certain smell i'll go
into the building i'm like korean people
were here yeah
i could tell yeah did was your setup
where like the girl there's like a
grown-up session and then the kids went
to
there's a youth section there's like a
whole youth building and then in easter
they would combine the services
and i [ __ ] hated it but in order to
get the donuts you'd have to go into the
main adult
yeah that's so funny it's like you're
just they're not religious [ __ ] at
all dude it's like my mom had no clue
like she
you know like wants her home one of her
homies got into jehovah's witness guess
what
all of his witness and then dude we
people don't know this
we attended [ __ ] uh the mormon church
for a minute
get the what korean [ __ ] goes to
[ __ ] the church of jesus christ for
of latter day saints dog
how long how long were you a mormon for
uh i don't know but dude
it was the most weird [ __ ]
experience really talk about you're the
only asian there
oh for sure yeah there's one black
family and then there's you
and all white it seems like your mom was
just looking for any type of salvation
this is elders just knocking on the door
and saying hi this is you know what i
mean missionary you know
there was a lot of like uh korean
jehovah witnesses that would come to the
house but then they didn't know my
father was a pastor
so i would always try to warn these
[ __ ] like hey hey
don't come to this house like my dad
will trap the wrong one so he's got the
[ __ ] wrong like
i remember the last time jehovah
witnesses came to our house it was these
two
ajamas that came oh yeah it's like have
you heard of jehovah like jehovah
witnesses and my dad was it was on a
sunday and my dad was like
perfect he's like come on in like well
we'll let's talk about it
they walk in and my dad has like a
library shelf
full of christian theology like he's
right yeah you're like i said you got
the wrong one
yeah today and i got the wrong i just
looked at these poor ladies i'm like you
should have left when you had the chance
how's their little um illustrated
pamphlet yeah
that thin little [ __ ] pamphlet gonna
[ __ ]
you know battle the the doctrines and so
my dad was just talking to him
about like like protestant and like
catholicism and like christian theology
for like eight hours and these people
got exhausted yeah
they were there for so long my mom made
the lunch and dinner yeah
and i was like you [ __ ] up you should
have left that's something i would never
do in like 10 life spans like oh 100
like go to random people's houses knock
on their [ __ ] door
intrude and be like hey can i talk to
you about god you know it's like
[ __ ] that it's it's a little odd i don't
know what the approach is i don't know
what the success rate of that is too
right like what's the percentage on this
[ __ ] it's got but that's the thing is
it's it's in numbers yeah that you got
god knows how many [ __ ]
doors they knock on oh a hundred percent
like hundreds of doors like hey
they must get good at your size you know
for you so like
you you got it to like wrap around let's
get back
off we got off on the korean [ __ ] we
always end up on the weekend
we can talk about that all right so i
got to remember okay so
this new album out during quarantine i
was watching movies
you know just random you know i was
bored and [ __ ] you know i was getting my
editing done i was doing everything but
i'm like
uh watch this and then i [ __ ] ran
across like old movies i used to love
this kid
like as a kid one of them was stir crazy
you know
gene wilder yeah and dude
i don't know when look when you saw that
last but i was
dying like they're their performances
together
i was [ __ ] especially both of them
together were just genius
and then i was like thinking like oh it
would be sick if
i could do some kind of concept music
project out of this
and so i that's when the seed was
planted i don't know i didn't know what
or how
but then i just started like just uh
i didn't bite their whole like every i
would take little
clips of yeah yeah [ __ ] and then i would
try to make a beat
and and [ __ ] around it and then whatever
um
whatever dialogue i i captured i would
try to make a whole concept like
um there's a a scene where like
uh richard pryor is in the hospital ward
and
he doesn't he's finding out his doctor's
korean oh yeah yeah yeah and then the
doctor
instead of the doctor saying how do you
do he goes how do you go
and so i i sampled just that how do you
go and i made a whole
song it's about like how do you go when
you die
you know what i mean because you know
people were passing away mf doom had
just passed
yeah [ __ ] double k from people under
the stairs had just passed so i'm like
oh i want to make
you know it's like more of a sentimental
kind of beat jazzy beat
and so that's just an example so i made
a whole [ __ ]
concept album just from me like just
watching [ __ ] that movie and getting
inspired are you producing all this
stuff yourself yeah i produced all of it
yeah and that that
that's the thing it took me a while
because i'm not one of those you know
musicians that are rappers that like
hey you got any hot beats i'm not one of
those guys
because for me this is for personal
reasons
i enjoy the
it's kind of like you paint you paint it
you paint the you color it in or you do
it yeah
instead of no i want to like do
do it i want to create the thing you
know like prince
yeah yeah i want to do it i want to do
it i want to
even if it sounds shitty like because i
did it on garageband
and my own little 303 sampler like
even if it's like hell of analog or
dusty
it's i am i made it yeah i i picked all
the stamp i
you know arranged it i did all found the
drum loop yeah i did it you know
this podcast is brought to you by raycon
my friends i don't know about you but i
feel like i'm always looking at a screen
now more than ever i wonder why and
whether you're an avid news watcher or
in serious need of a distraction
unplugging yourself is easier said than
done my friends one of my favorite ways
to rest my eyes and still get content
i'm itching for
putting on my raycon wireless earbuds
your freaking sillies raycon earbuds
sound quality amazing price even better
and there's a lot of people out there
that are selling their expensive earbuds
but guess what
raycon sounds just as good if not maybe
even better
raycons are built to perform anywhere
and anytime with water and sweat
resistant construction and bluetooth
that pairs
quickly and seamlessly the best part
raycon makes great sound accessible to
everyone with wireless earbuds starting
at half the price
of other premium audio brands raycon's
offering 15
off all their products from my listeners
and here's what you've got to do to get
it
go to buy recon dot com slash brain and
that's it
you'll get 15 off your entire raycon
order so feel free to grab
a pair and a spare that's 15 off at buy
raycon.com
brain that's by raycon.com brain
yeah i can't it's music it's kind of
consuming music is [ __ ] hard
it's time consuming like i can't imagine
the the production side of things right
like because
the production part is like the hardest
like it is
but it's the most rewarding because i'll
tell you why the and this is i'm glad i
thought of this
to me it's all it is is a puzzle
all that's all it is to me it's like
it's a puzzle and how am i gonna
make this fit into this you know what
i'm saying i'm talking about samples and
the way you arrange the way i do it yeah
yeah and so to me
it's kind of like doing a word you know
a word puzzle or something
and that's like and then once you figure
it out because sometimes
you're trying to fit this with this and
it's just not working
but then once you get rid of this and
then find another piece and then
it like it works yeah and it they click
together then you're like oh it's like
you found the holy grail or something
you were also you when you were doing
the uh you were on a in a band with
david
yeah wait how did that how did that
start okay
so wait hold up before i forget
stevieweebybandcamp.com that's where you
get we're gonna get back
steviewbandcamp.com
i feel stir crazy get that [ __ ] it's
gonna be awesome
get that [ __ ] get that [ __ ] okay so my
brother
this is obviously pretty uh corona
yeah covered whatever long time ago
where he picked me up he was like you
want to get some korean bbq i'm like
[ __ ] yeah
we're heading towards koreatown he
[ __ ]
like we're almost there and then he's
like oh [ __ ]
and i go what he goes [ __ ] i forgot i
had to do this thing man
will you just come with me i go what
where do you have to go he's like i got
to do this podcast
and back then i didn't even know what
that meant what
what what what is that just come with me
dude
calm i'm like all right you know back
then i'm a little different now i'm more
like open to [ __ ] like that yeah
back then i was so stubborn no dude i
want to get let's get some bulgogi you
know like [ __ ] dude you were here
yeah he's like dude i promised this guy
i promised him i go
so we ended up going to david cho's
warehouse yeah he didn't tell me that
he just said oh this is my friend i
promised and so i ended up just
going to this place and
and i'm like first of all like it was he
had his own warehouse like
the thing opened and he drove in he had
his own and there's paintings the
unfinished paintings and
a drum kit it was just crazy and i'm
like
what the and then i'm already thinking
who is this guy
so he he brings me in there and he's
like
and this is when dvdsa were that's the
podcast it was dvd it was awesome
and david cho and so they had the
podcast room with
stuff like this the gear and i'm like
whoa
i was like some serious [ __ ] it was a
serious thing yeah but you know me like
i like to be give courtesy you know
so i showed him respect because i
realized oh this david [ __ ]
show
i was already a fan of his art like i
knew his art i'm a fan you know
i gave him respect i go i i just thank i
just want
good menia i like your [ __ ] and so i
took literally one of the podcast chairs
i grabbed it and i walked it way to the
the corner door away from them
you know you guys do your thing i'll
just i'm doing i'm just gonna stay here
yeah so i think a couple minutes in
dave's like hey bring your brother over
here
you know get because also wasn't there
that i
cause i sat in her seat they had an
extra seat
and so that was literally like the first
time i did this type of [ __ ]
where i ended up just freakishly
getting on the podcast
you know and then i didn't know what i
was doing but people liked it
and then i ended up coming back again
and i ended up coming back again and
again and again and again to the point
where i finally
i got to meet like money mark and then
assa
finally and then and one day during one
of the podcasts
dave's like you guys want to record
music
what the [ __ ] it was like kind of some
random [ __ ] you know
and so did he know that you did music
not really
because this is what happened this is on
some real [ __ ] like okay so
at the time i did my final ep called
durb flame pencil
um and it was a concept album like
a pencil a dura flame pencil you know
like the pencil you write with dirt
flame you throw that
it catches on fire you burn it's done so
that was a concept album like this is my
last ep
i'm done with music yeah you know and i
had quit
gave it up like the four track was all
my gear was in my closet i'm
[ __ ] done you know i was frustrated
you know i put so much time and effort
into this [ __ ] and so i
and then i was working at fat cells at a
sandwich shop
okay so i'm working at a sandwich shop
and then i just
luckily go going to korean barbecue
freakishly ended up at david cho's
podcast meeting these cool people
and then we ended up [ __ ] going dude
he rented this
crazy like summer camp law cabin type
[ __ ] like no not normal like there was
different bunkers it was a whole
like cabin resort like he he rented it
for like two weeks or some [ __ ] he's an
interesting guy dude
like i like it was crazy dude my only
introduction to him was obviously first
was obviously a dvd series like i only
listened to a couple of episodes but
yeah everybody was talking about that
podcast right
and i was like well who's david joe and
then we talked obviously that went into
him
you know paying that mural for facebook
yeah all the money that he made oh yeah
and then recently i listened to the
the podcast with him and rogan yeah and
i was like
i listened to every all four hours
whatever i was like so
this is david cho like yeah like i went
to the congo yeah
to look for a dinosaur i'm like what in
the [ __ ] is going on oh yeah i don't
want anybody to tell me that i'm weird
like i am not weird no but the thing
about him
is i didn't realize like art right
i thought oh [ __ ] you know pens and
paint brush
like no like i learned this
the hard way like we're in minnesota
this is after we form monchi
we're doing a show and one of the people
like that was in charge of the venue was
like
hey we're looking for dave we have these
spray cans can you
can he we wanted him to do art can you
try to do something
and so you know i thought i could i've
never [ __ ] with spray cans but
like i like took the i didn't know about
can control
my i like how they're looking for david
cho right this famous artist is like
well can you do something
that's what that's what happened i tried
i tried my best it looked like a
five-year-old did it
and let me tell you when he got a hand
of that can
it it i was in shock of the
what he was able like he was doing [ __ ]
with it it took him
like a couple seconds he was like and it
looked like
like the [ __ ] like a china chinese
dude with like a rice hat like it looks
so detailed
yeah and what and then i like asked him
after like
there's like techniques where he would
like put off
his finger uh cunning the the airway or
like
the cap halfway to make the lines more
you know like
yeah this is going back like to art and
understanding like the different mediums
like i had
[ __ ] no idea like and that's not even
adding like how good he is at water
coloring
but anyway i'm getting off track so
you're saying okay i was talking about
big bear in the the cabin yeah
and [ __ ] yeah so we're we went there
and
um money mark brought uh like all of his
gear
and dude we ended up recording what is
known as
our first maangchi album that's [ __ ]
crazy and but i know this because they
knew uh
i think they were kind of testing out
the waters like they're seeing if i was
able to rise
to the occasion of like doing this [ __ ]
and they i i
i know this they pulled me aside one
night at the kitchen table this place is
huge by the way like there's
there's a pool table there's like like
laundry there's everything it was like
and they they pulled me aside and
they're like um we want to do this music
but steve we want you to be open-minded
like we might want to do some singing
[ __ ]
we might want to do some punk [ __ ] we
might want to do some like top four like
top 40
whatever we just want you to be open so
to it and
but i remember um oh cause this is crazy
because you you
you're in the movie [ __ ] right yeah yeah
so
i had recorded a a song called [ __ ] boy
and it was on uh like just my i was
working on a solo project because
i think he said like hey you could do
your solo [ __ ] as well
because they later put that out on vinyl
and [ __ ] and so
we were trying to like figure out how to
do music and what and then they're like
it was like
mid-afternoon they're like hey don't you
bring your album let's hear some of it
and so when i had brought that out they
i let them preview some of the songs and
then
mark told me to play the goop boy song
and so what ended up happening is he
ended up i ended up canning that on my
solo album and we ended up redoing that
for like i think that's the first song
we worked on
oh wow yeah and so mark did some [ __ ]
and then um
and then i think the second song was
like these are my people and then
and you know he's such a genius in his
own right and [ __ ] you know what
i do he was drinking wine he was
drinking wine and
it was me david money mark it was late
and he was getting a bit tipsy and he he
was like
he was talking about adam yeah uh
heading out from the beastie boys oh
yeah yeah you know because he had passed
and he he basically said if he was still
alive
i wouldn't even be here with you guys
the [ __ ]
yeah i don't think he meant it like that
but me and dave we were just
like looking at each other like
uncomfortable i was like
thanks dude like i wouldn't even be
[ __ ] with you guys if this other guy
was here you're
still alive just like you guys would be
just
so how long were you guys uh are you
guys still going strong or no
no it's hiatus right now i mean we had a
run man like
you're touring yeah like we ended up
[ __ ]
doing it um we ended up opening we did
an east coast tour
west coast tour [ __ ] we even went up
to canada we ended up opening
for deltron 30 30. oh [ __ ] we ended up
opening up for dying antwoord
uh die antwerp yeah yeah yeah and um
[Music]
and then you know and it was [ __ ]
really fun man i mean he got a whole
[ __ ]
motley crew tour he got a whole tour bus
with our
yeah like our decal over there and [ __ ]
i'm like what the [ __ ]
so when you guys what what type of music
did maangchi do just editing it was like
[ __ ] rapping cowboy rapping punk
uh singing it was just everything you
know that's that's just going back to
like
you know because dave's such a gene like
he's so open to just everything
you know and so like yeah i think it
just ran its course i had a
[ __ ] great time with them i mean
they're still my family like
yeah still how many years was that [ __ ]
dude um
god that's a good question
because we had disbanded and then steve
aoki
promised to do a [ __ ] show at uh
a fashion week in new york what the [ __ ]
it was
dude let me tell you it was the weirdest
[ __ ] show ever so
he's like we want to book you guys but
it's gonna be at
like a modeling fashion gear for uh
denmark for his clothing line yeah yeah
and so
it was literally have you seen devil
wears prada
yes it was awesome devil wears prada
[ __ ] like imagine those types of people
in the crowd
did you just ask steve do you know what
the [ __ ] we are no no but this is a
thing it was even more weird because
there was skateboarding ramps so there's
like skateboarding actors yeah like
stunt people
like skating while we're performing on
top of this mini ramp
and no one paying attention oh my god
dude i
i those performances are the worst like
i hate that [ __ ] and so literally
it was like we're like i'm we're
sweating out you know doing our thing
and people are just like
you know like did this you're just
eating hors d'oeuvres
[ __ ] martini and [ __ ] exactly there's
some new york [ __ ] yeah
some fashion week and then that happened
and then we had we and then that was i
think the last thing we did
um and then i'll tell you this i mean
this is not bad this is true
actually but then later down the line we
heard from the grapevine like
steve aoki wants to remix one of our
songs
so i'm like whoa really this is big time
yeah you know and so what ended up
happening is
he did remix a song but guess what
he cut out all my audio
[Laughter]
you're like what an honor you [ __ ]
bastard
so but we had hired a morgan freeman
voice over actor at the beginning of the
song he
remixed was called the best and so we
hired this actor
that sounds exactly like morgan freeman
and he's just
talking before the song even begins
stevie uncle took his voice oh my god
but he cut all your [ __ ] vocalist voices
that's [ __ ] funny he's like i want to
remix your [ __ ] basically i just want to
delete you know stephen
yeah you're leaving yeah that's [ __ ]
funny man so
just can you imagine me being so pumped
like oh my god
because he's big yeah oh he remixed our
song
you know this is gonna rejuvenate our
our whole group and
you know he looks like a wife japanese
sage that's what he looks like
every time i see steve aoki i want to
see him with the staff flying on a cloud
or something
he is kind of biblical in that and he's
biblical in the sense of like
even when he was like walking out to
these fashion people like he was like
he was like jesus christ walking out and
[ __ ] he was like sometimes i watched he
was doing this [ __ ]
dude like steve aoki interact with
people i'm like stevie you ain't gotta
do all that bro like you ain't got to
clash your hands and start bouncing oh
he was doing this [ __ ] i was like steve
you've never done that before in your
life
i'm telling you just like don't do that
i was tripping i was like
he's like a godhead oh for sure
god imagine his house huh
he's got the oh water slides or his ball
pit
his dad's supposed to be somebody famous
too right dude he [ __ ]
owns benihana oh is that what he did see
the documentary you gotta watch the
doctor
i never saw the dog don't watch the
doctor's dad owns benny hannah he's the
dude yeah
i was just rich people just keep getting
there and a dog hey
how many times have we not a lot of my
parents spending
my [ __ ] parents on a black beauty
supply store your dad [ __ ] sells
questions
my dad owned fashion gas yeah
what's the fashion you don't know about
it people don't even know the sweatshop
district
back in the day these clothing stores
were poppin dude like korean people
owned all these photos
we're getting back into the creation
right now i'm preparing i'm preparing
right now but you want to do this again
yeah i'll just do it all the time i'll
do it let's go i already got something
ready
right after you i got something ready
right after you man
you're talking about myself
[Applause]
not only that dude is i found out later
dude
the forever 21 guess where they're
getting all their [ __ ]
fashion district oh yeah forever 21 was
originally creamy bread
they're korean people huh fat yeah
fashion district
yeah but this is why
they succeeded in a like our ajamas and
our emo booze shops failed
and i wouldn't be real those are aunts
and uncles yeah because
yeah we had the same [ __ ] inventory
but guess what presentation
is everything that's what i'm talking
about so what they did
is they hired they went to the same
place to get their [ __ ]
but they hired younger koreans that were
more in the know fashionable like no
they knew about aesthetics yeah yeah
yeah and that's all you know they got
the chandelier
the [ __ ] marble floor there you go
that was the uh that's like the same
concept with the like panda express
those little fast food chinese spots
have been around a long time we survived
off them oh yeah
that's right like we would save up for
that meal oh for sure
oh [ __ ] i got four dollars and 35 cents
and it's crazy because like panda
express two
is not as good as those mom and pop shop
ones are no they're
they just market it better yeah it's
clean they have a sign
yeah the presentation's cleaner the
[ __ ] water is not next to the garbage
can
dude i don't know what about you know
this there's another thing that
fascinates me about koreans it's like
they never choose a profession
that they're even like at all you notice
that it's like
huh how do i make money laundry mat
this podcast is brought to you by june b
matcha do you hate the jitters and crash
that coffee gives you well say
no more my friends because hundreds of
thousands of people are drinking junebe
matcha not only for the health benefits
but for the caffeine boost that lasts
without the crash of coffee you can mix
it
have it hot ice cold or try it with your
favorite juices and have
fun with it remember not all matcha is
created the same and junebe has the
highest quality matcha you can find
straight from a farm in japan
hand-picked and curated to get you the
best
quality there is no competition to get
10
off your first order of tins and packets
go to junebeshop.com
that's j-u-n-b-i shop.com and enter code
geniusbrain to get 10
off your first order that's
b i j-u-n-b-i-s dot com code geniusbrain
what but what do you think that is let's
let's [ __ ] examine that that has
something to do with the old country
that's like on some [ __ ] we don't we
don't need
we don't care if we don't like it it
makes money type [ __ ] like yeah i don't
i don't think like
i think it has to do with like korean
resilience right yeah it has something
to do with that like
whatever it takes whatever it takes it
doesn't matter because my parents were
working like two three jobs too when
they first came here yeah so there was
no complaints there was no like oh
uh i don't want to so my mom had to
clean hotels my dad was a mechanic
and then he also worked for somebody
else's beauty supply store at the time
and they never complained it was just no
like i got to pay my bills this is what
it is
yeah another example liquor stores oh
liquor stores is another one
i mean we all seen minutes to society
yeah
i feel sorry for your mother yeah
yeah what did you say laundromats liquor
stores and uh beauty supply stores and
then okay it's like the the right
this is going back to the whole like
okay you wanna
you're you're a bit racist towards a
certain group of people but you're gonna
order oh
you're gonna get a liquor store in their
[ __ ] hood yeah yeah yeah
act like you're good now yeah yeah you
know what i mean that's like what the
[ __ ] it was weird
too because like when i when i i talked
about the slot too where
you i think like perceptively in that
community too
because like you know black americans
weren't given business loans but then
you see these random people from asia
come over and i'll be pissed off too if
i see some korean [ __ ]
in my neighborhood they're like and
they're making all the money exactly
what the [ __ ] are these people doing and
the crazy thing was like i i i remember
too like
uh customers thinking that we made a lot
of money but my parents didn't make a
lot of money at all we were barely
getting by
you know we had to pay rent for the
overhead and it was weird
it's a more gatorade they would come in
and they're like oh well you guys have
you have all this money i'm like you
we're broke like i don't know what
you're done
no no no think about it okay if i live
in that neighborhood right
and i want to get a beer how much was a
40 back then yeah yeah yeah
two dollars yeah a buck 50. there you go
you just saw the saint ives yeah it's
like you know like this neighborhood
that the store is in i live in the same
neighborhood you live in like
i'm also broke with you like we don't we
don't have a lot of money like it's just
not so
crazy their mentality is as far as well
it's just hard because they see
you know people you're in a movie where
it's all about yeah it was
a shoe store it's like a
misunderstanding you know it's like one
one like korean people too like i said
like when we immigrated here too
our perception of like american culture
black american culture mexican culture
is
all or whatever the stuff that's not
ours is based on what people told us
because we don't know we come into this
country blank as [ __ ]
and the problem with that is that you
know asian people too they just
they don't question a lot of things you
know because there's like
govern loyalty to government and
everything else in this country is a
little different
so when they're fed all these like false
ideas or negative ideas like
specifically about black culture it kind
of sticks with them you know not only
that i think that
once koreans or any kind of asian
family gets accustomed or integrated
more like as
years go by their attitude changes as
well for sure
my mom's had my pops and recipes like
they they've changed
yeah it takes a while then before you
know it
oh his golfing homie there's a hispanic
guy there's a black you know
yeah my dad's got homies from different
races he's playing golf with
yeah so you know what i'm saying like
that generation in this country is going
away now too so
what do you mean like the the the the
more like
racially ignorant like immigrants those
people are going away because now we
live in like a very global
yeah it's super global because the
internet oh so yeah
you know what that's that's fascinating
that's interesting you brought that up
yeah that that definitely because the
exposure yeah the exposures they just
look on their computer they're like oh
exactly there's an indian guy this
person's from the middle east
you know like different races yeah this
perception of of like i think
um kind of the racist asian
it's it's a little dated now like it's
that's like when did that go that's like
90s [ __ ]
exactly so like that that died off in
the 90s right yeah it's dying out now
right just because now with second
generation third generation fourth
generation think about the 92 riots that
must have been at the climax right
because you had these
korean [ __ ] with ak forces
you know what they're like the police
ain't going to help us
well people didn't understand this
either it was like at the time
you know when they were thinking that
they were going people were just going
to bust into these korean stores
they didn't know that all these korean
men they went to four years of military
in korea
yeah they know how to use like you got
the wrong one there too
you got the wrong one not only that i
like the fact because you do videos on
like
because a lot of you know like these
random people attacking a random
old asian lady or a man or something
yeah you're
you're kind of playing with fire there
let me remind you
uh virginia tech cho
i don't know i just want to take a walk
down history lane here
dude virginia tech cho
you're you got the wrong one you got the
[ __ ] wrong
one i mean i guarantee you you know what
i'm saying because if you look at that
dude because i still watch his videos
like i'm trying to
figure out the psychology of this cat
well well this is what's going on that's
a firecracker dude well this is what's
going to happen
it's like it's going to be an old it's
going to be an old korean lady that's
going to get attacked
it's like oh you shouldn't have attacked
me plan it out yeah
they'll study that [ __ ] like it's their
midterm yeah i'm going to chain
adore c to door 3b to whole
entryway to watch korean films uh some
so have you seen like uh one of my
favorite ones called i saw the devil
yeah i think i did yeah that is one of
these it's all about vengeance just like
the whole series
highly violent yeah yeah yeah and a
korean person thought about that for a
film
yeah you know what i'm saying yeah so
like i always get you know when those
attacks were happening too it's just
like
people were asking me like what i what i
thought about it right and the only
thing i could really think of is like
well there's a few things it's like
asian people are it's not passive it's
it's more like
my parents had this idea of if somebody
wants to verbally assault me or do
whatever it's like i'm the business
owner
like i'm the one working yeah like i
don't have to care about the opinions of
somebody who's beneath me
and that's how my parents would kind of
would you say that now because you know
you're successful and you're like doing
your content your comedy and film and
everything it doesn't work that way now
just because
it's a different generation right right
so now it was just
it was about getting by well now that
we're past getting by
and there is a youth with a voice yeah
people are going to want to speak up
sometimes it gets a little annoying
right but at the same time like we need
those people to kind of say stuff just
because if you don't it's just going to
keep happening over and over again
asian people only we're only five
percent of this country's population
yeah but not only that is another thing
asians do
they know how to hold it in and let me
tell you boy
it builds up oh for sure you know like
and that's i think going back to the
virginia tech [ __ ] here's this [ __ ]
kid probably didn't have a lot of homies
probably stayed he was in his dorm room
he was bullied a little bit
bullied yeah and one day he was just
like
all right you got the wrong one i'm
gonna start researching
handcuffs i'm gonna go to the shooting
range i'm gonna
plant this i'm gonna get these cha he
planned it out and [ __ ]
well yeah i mean i think people too like
if you keep pushing people to a corner
something bad is going to happen right
don't do that especially out in new york
like
i'm not sure if like american people
even understand this [ __ ] like
new york specifically when it comes to
chinese people they're
highly connected into like chinese mafia
that's why i love watching china max
[ __ ] so much
because he speaks on like you know
empowering asians
well i've i i watch a video of china mac
and my ass starts to sweat
like this guy [ __ ] this guy this guy
scares me
there's a video of this i love china max
shout out to china mac man i'm a fan of
china magic dude i love your [ __ ] i love
his music love his [ __ ]
being interviewed and they were having a
conversation
about the the usage of the n-word right
and then chinamak doesn't use it anymore
because he understands what it
what it means right so he's been in
prison so he doesn't use it anymore
right
but then somebody said he's like look if
trying to max at the end i'd smack him
and then all of a sudden the fruit gets
dead quiet oh yeah and then china
looks and he goes you smack me he goes
i've never been smacked a day in my life
you smack me
and he goes no that's that's not what i
said right yeah yeah i've never seen
this
a dude double back on his words so hard
in my life
don't [ __ ] with china mac just don't
[ __ ] with that guy and you see his homie
just like chilling yeah in the corner
and you could tell his homie is ready to
go like he's like oh she's about to go
down i'm about to [ __ ] people up
and then trying to max like you ain't
gonna smack me like nothing's happening
i'm watching this video
yeah yeah yeah he meant it he meant it
too yeah i sweated through my shirt oh
yeah he's not even next this happened
two years ago
yeah i'm such a fan of china max i watch
his food vlogs
man he's got recipes like they're called
spreads
yeah you know he knows how to make a
burrito out of like
doritos food right now
dog he knows how to make guitars he
knows how to make a burrito
crunching up doritos and and top ramen
is like the
the crust have you tried eating that
prison food before
no but i'm fascinated because you know
why i like it because it's like
it makes me think of like yeah i like to
put myself in different people's
predicaments and [ __ ] like [ __ ] yeah i
could probably try some [ __ ] like that
because i've gone through like in
arizona you know when i was going
to asu at the end i was like hella broke
oh for sure
like i would steal food off in the
cafeteria
you know food court taco bell put some
of that in my backpack
you know and so like i always think like
i mean there's one
time uh there was like a community
kitchen
i was so broke and hungry i hadn't eaten
for a long time that
i was so hungry i [ __ ] just opened
the community refrigerator
and i saw some gross old moldy ass top
ramen
in the pot like probably weeks old and i
just said
[ __ ] it i'm scratching are you waiting i
just grabbed it i was so i mean this is
how i was starving
i grabbed it and i just [ __ ] put it
on the um that stove the kitchen the
community stove
and i just said [ __ ] it i'm eating this
why the [ __ ] were you so broke
okay so there's a thing called like
a food plan like it's like kind of like
a a student id card yeah kind of like
you like yeah like we
then they're called blocks you got and
we got like the lowest
amount that my mom we didn't know yeah
and i didn't want to like because they
were struggling at the time as well you
know even though we did get in
state tuition at the time because my
parents had moved to chandler or
whatever
before moving to gilbert and um and so i
just didn't want to bother them and be
like
i need more you know blocks on this card
you know so
so that's when the homies would like
sneak me into the cafeteria i had to do
what i had to do
that's crazy yeah but going back to
china mac and like why i like watching
those it reminds me of that the present
spreads
i don't know what it has to do with
prison spreads but it fascinates me
watching prison spread like tutorials
you just get emotional you're thinking
about that ramen you had to heat up it's
like i missed that
yeah no but dude that's when like even
back then it's like because how much is
a packet of ramen like 29 cents or some
[ __ ]
like even you said it was like 10 cents
it was nothing but you could eat that
even like without cooking it like as
like
oh a hundred percent like a big like you
could crush that [ __ ] up and then salt
it
yeah so i would eat it like that too
damn you know what the funny thing is
you probably could have just called your
mom and she would have given you
something
it's you know what this is this is like
my downfall but i think
it's the that [ __ ] pride yeah you
know that korean pride [ __ ] where you're
just like i don't want to ask
well i i had like issues with that too
it's funny because when i was i went to
ucr
yeah and then there was something wrong
with my financial aid what you said is
that
uh university of california riverside
riverside riverside yeah and there was
something wrong with my financial aid
and so my check didn't come in
but then just like you i was so [ __ ]
prideful i couldn't ask my parents for
money
yeah because i knew we didn't have a lot
of money either and it's so weird like
you just
you you don't want to burden them you
know what i mean you're already helping
with tuition
and yeah you're almost done and [ __ ] to
ask your parents for something that they
would gladly
give you know what i mean did you have
were you actually doing like the real
college [ __ ] that you were supposed to
be doing like
no i did terrible school i was just
doing drugs and skateboarding around
campus
i uh my first year so i didn't want to
go
to a university at all i wanted to go to
well i did i wanted to go to community
college first
yeah and then transfer over into a
university later but my parents that's a
smart move
you would think but then my parents were
about you know well you have to go to
university
because what [ __ ] korean kid doesn't
get into a university after high school
so i was forced to go to ucr which there
was only two colleges that would accept
me it was uc merced they just opened up
and they were taking every crackhead
possible yeah and then ucr i didn't even
apply to and they said i got in
that happened with me in asu that's like
oh i got accepted
i was like i didn't know plot what are
you talking about yeah so i went to ucr
and so when i when i went there i
didn't like it because i didn't have any
goals i didn't want to be there
so the first year i almost got kicked
out and oh yeah what was your gpa
oh [ __ ] was like two point some [ __ ]
point four five
you're okay point four
so you literally did nothing okay i'm
sorry
you have to try to get a 0.45
surfer dude from like malibu he'd wait
literally wake up in the morning and go
he'd be like
bong rip deep oh my god
i would just be like and then how the
[ __ ] do you have a .45
i don't know what what is that all f
that's like
that's like a that's like a negative z
like a dog like how the [ __ ] did you get
a point four five i didn't i didn't know
i
there's a dude let me tell you there is
one class i went to
no wonder you couldn't ask your parents
for [ __ ] food you [ __ ] failure
i was at this child development class i
don't even know what i signed up for
i didn't realize i didn't even have the
right book for the whole semester
i didn't even know this is how dude
don't look down on me please
i'm being honest it was like i was in
the classroom
and i was it was one of those things
where it's like you're in the classroom
and you're looking around you're looking
around hold up you're looking around and
you're like
wait a minute i don't i don't have
the i don't have the book that they have
but you know what's so [ __ ] up
about this human being right here he's
so [ __ ] prideful he just said [ __ ]
i'm gonna pretend
until check this out and tell the
professor how to intervene
she knew because i look like a lost dog
the whole semester
i would literally people would be doing
their [ __ ] doing their workshop
[ __ ] and i'd be like i would just be
like
looking around lost like
so one day
she goes um stephen uh would you uh
meet me at my office uh today at 4 30.
uh we need to
talk about some things and so she
literally it's
i don't know she did this with any other
students like she like
i don't know what term you would call it
she partitioned me here
she did something where she had to act
like
i let's just you didn't take this class
it's
this didn't count we'll enroll you
inside she's like i'm like the dumber
club i have never seen
somebody pretend to read a book for a
month straight she goes you are a
talented human being
i like oh she was like also your book
was upside down for a while
no this is how i include i didn't even
know
how where to get the book
she's like like oh you have to go
to the designated
college book a store i literally
i literally pictured you sitting in
class and then just
everyday everything just like yo why
does this kid
keep looking around as if he doesn't
belong here don't put that then there's
nothing
i was faking it until i made it i was
like acting like i was doing their [ __ ]
i was like writing raps and [ __ ] i was
like i was acting like i was doing their
[ __ ] i felt like she was very proud of
you because you had perfect attendance
i was there every day why did you even
show up
i don't know why you show up
that's a very good question
this is going back to like this is like
this going back to like just my pride
and i thought back then i could fake
them i just i'm like you know what
i it's kind of like you fake it till you
make it i'm like
oh i can you know i'm just blending in
that would be so defensive
somebody looks at you they go yo you got
the wrong book i'm like [ __ ] you got
the wrong book the [ __ ] are you talking
about
like you know i just had a regular
me notebook you could buy a rat like at
target i just had a regular binder
don't put nothing in it like trying to
yeah i think this is what i have now
in my defense
just let me just hear me out i think
i was i got a regular binder not the
real
not the real literature to at least try
uh-huh at least give me this i attempted
to take notes i don't give a [ __ ]
i don't give a [ __ ] bro i don't care
that you
i tried i tried i tried to take what you
said
i don't even know what classes that's
why i was even more confused
because they're doing thesis and they're
actually
there i this is the class
they're about to be in the working
profession as in child development
they're doing their final you know their
final exams
you know and uh i was just lost
why did you show up for the [ __ ] i
don't know
why i showed up i don't know why
why did you show up for the test you
knew you weren't going to pass it
you didn't even
they would um post the grades
at the bulletin like outside the certain
building designated buildings
and i just remember like looking for my
name and i would like
i'll be looking and then i would see the
f and i would just start crying
[Laughter]
what are you surprised
was suspect
i don't want my mom to watch
it took me nine years to graduate
[Laughter]
let that sink in it took me night it
took me nine years to graduate man
it took me nine years i don't even know
what degree it is
i i don't know what i got i have a
diploma
in my desk at home i don't even david i
have no idea
what the journal is it's called the
interdisciplinary studies
i have no idea what that even means
i have no i have no idea what i have
it's
basically they should have said this
this degree
is for dum-dums i like you
oh man i'm sorry my mom can't watch it
though
i'm sorry i'm sorry you got me crying
too
you're the first one to question why i
showed up
no no no family has ever asked me that
you're the only one thank you
thank you thank you for asking me why
your mom thank you about this she said
why'd you go
no i thought it was good i mean
according to her i was killing it
but as a year five run around year six
that drive to the university got a
little bit more
suspicious you'd just be like driving
it'd be quiet
so you're gonna do it this year it's
been a nine years
should you be a doctor i just remember
our graduating class
was like five people have left the
corner
yo you're like yo you know how there's
like main
people who stand up and you know yeah
people business like ours was like uh
like
like five people like just like just the
people that the business system
you just keep getting conquered from
prison and you can't stop
like you just can't stop like if your
mom asked you if you were a doctor
she would buy a stethoscope the next day
then you would just kind of put on a
diploma
and you would have to [ __ ] that
little silver cap
dude i it was almost i went to
student student admissions to see um
you know a counselor there and she did
when she looked up my
my stats and like my grades
it she was shocked she was like trying
to figure out and you've been here how
many years
and so she had to figure out oh we gotta
get you out of the system and so i think
interdisciplinary studies
was something they had to create
to get people like me out of their
system i was there so long i live i
would always go the same dorm i almost
lit on like every corner i've lived in
so many different dorm rooms there you
were in the same
dorm for nine years no i was at
manzanita and then i went over to
uh uh across campus uh at this place
called ocotillo because the rooms
uh you didn't have to there was no
inside hallway it was like this old
motel that they converted years later
into a dorm
so it was it was the size of a prison
you were you're van wilder dude
what do you what do you mean you're
[ __ ] van wilder van waals
the the [ __ ] super college dude he
stayed in college until he for like
eight years that's
me for sure you're [ __ ] van they're
the asian van wilder dude so you could
buy alcohol for everybody in the dorms
and [ __ ]
oh my god how was that [ __ ] funny
i just might have said you're the first
person to ask why did you sh
that's a very good question i didn't
need to did i
you didn't have to go but but there's a
part of me
i'm trying to think of my thought
process
a part of me thought i could fool them
why
but i wasn't fooling anyone
like there's a professor just so
confused like this guy
has not figured it out why is he here
and he's here on time
every day i just remember it was like
midterm week and i'm like
on mushrooms and just like laying in my
dorm room bed
staring at the ceiling like seeing
ghosts like look down my god
i was out there man that's [ __ ] crazy
so you're doing shrooms you're doing
everything
everything dude this would be my daily
routine so i would
fake go into my car like i would go to
my classes
and so i had like some kind of sense of
accomplishment
and me and the homie joe munoz he was
the older native american homie because
i ended up moving into the native
american there was like african-american
section native american section it was
like more like our peoples you know like
minority you know
people ethnic people yeah i met this guy
he was in the graffiti he liked the same
type of hip hop like he was in a [ __ ]
dubious inside [ __ ] and
so we would literally i'd watch he was
older
every night i'd watch him with this
jansport backpack
walking towards the liquor store and
then i found out
this guy drank uh double deuces
every night oh this was a [ __ ]
stereotype huh
but that does not he did this for real
though oh wow like we
and then i started doing that like out
every night
i would drink before i ate you know what
i'm saying maybe that's why i was so
[ __ ]
hungry all the time because it would
mostly be beer yeah
so every night we'd walk over to the
walk and we'd come up
back and with the backpack filled with
the old e double deuces or
back then where king cobra whatever did
the trick you know what i mean and so
that was my [ __ ] nightly routine god
damn
i was i became an alcohol that's what
happened how the [ __ ] are you alive
i don't know how the [ __ ] are you alive
i don't know
that's [ __ ] nuts to me i don't know
so you start wait when
when was the first time you had a
that's a good question um
i think it was my older cousin paul choi
he was older than us
and he um had bought i remember uh
have you heard of strawberry hill it's
like this cheap wine
so he had bought this bottle of
strawberry hill i think
and then i drank that and i remember
throwing up
but then when i really started drinking
was in um you know because i i wrestled
i was ranked second in
cali i was supposed to win the state
tournament in my senior year but i
choked
that's pretty [ __ ] amazing though i
choked i choked and so
you know the program i was raised i mean
poway is known for the wrestling program
like i was they they grew me since like
sixth grade like to to win
state or you know and uh i had choked
and then i went into such a depression
that i just
you know i that had happened then i'm
like
[ __ ] it i started going to the house
parties [ __ ] it give me that
let me smoke that and and then i got
miraculously got accepted to ac arizona
and uh
and that's when it it progressed oh yeah
yeah that's great because i i i think
the first time i had an alcohol i was
like 13.
yeah i was super young and it was always
like from a homie or like a cousin or
some [ __ ] yeah
it was my cousin yeah yeah it was my
cousin he's always some family [ __ ] huh
yeah
he snuck uh some e and j from his dad's
like little
some hard liquor yeah and then he put it
into a an arrowhead bottle there you go
and then we just we just drank that
night yeah and that was the first time
i'd alcohol [ __ ] yeah
yeah and that's i stopped drinking
probably a lot a lot
when i was when i hit 21. really so it
was like from 13
all the way till like i was 21 and then
21 i stopped a bit
and then when i moved to k-town
is it is it wild down there i mean like
living there and [ __ ]
the k-town was fun man like especially
when i was single right so it's like
when i was single and it was like tell
me about the clubs what what is it
popping like the club scene well not not
now because of like rona but
i know but before then oh for sure like
it
domes like the king over there huh dumb
and wrecked shout out to dumbledore i
mean everybody so i used to have this
big-ass apartment out in k-town it was
like a
it was like a 3 400 square foot
apartment yeah it was
in the middle of cape town it's like
this older building huge [ __ ] spot
so we had me and my roommate
specifically my buddy ed
he won this video competition with
general soju
damn and so we endorsement deal [ __ ] so
he won a life's
a lifetime supply of it like a year
worth supply or some [ __ ] yeah and so
his room was just stacked with just
general bottles oh
so every night we would just tell people
to come over and drink
so almost every other night we had a
party at our what's the alcohol content
what kind of liquor is that [ __ ]
oh that's soju yeah oh so we would drink
soju every night
dub would come over anderson pack
everybody oh they would just come
through
yeah because we would just leave the
door unlocked like just [ __ ] come
through and drink and so we would just
throw house parties all day
yeah until we and we killed that whole
year supply in like six months
damn that must have been quite a scene
it was fun i don't remember a lot of it
like we drank a lot though like we
dreamed
would be coming through too everybody
just everybody yeah it was it was so
would you say k-town has its own like
culture like subculture within it and
[ __ ] hey before like these bloggers and
[ __ ]
they used to because they blowed it and
they blew it out yeah they kind of did
stupid [ __ ] like for example there's a
lot of these speakeasies right
so you know in la after 2 a.m all liquor
spots shut down
so about them though those those those
hit those down the low
on the down low exactly there's a bunch
of these speakeasies that we would go to
but these [ __ ] little bloggers would
talk about yo i went to k-town and so
they would get shut down they blew it up
yeah it's like what the [ __ ] are you
doing dude shut the [ __ ] up
well you gotta confront them be like
dude you can't be doing that [ __ ] yeah
you're gonna blow up our spot
so we used to do we used to do that so
from 2 a.m and then after we
go to the late night spots from 2 a.m
all the way till like 8 a.m we drink and
then we wake up but we do it again
you know i always there's also this
darker side well because i used to go
i forgot where it is the sauna the
24-hour saunas
me and bob would go there but then this
one had like a ping pong table
and a pool tables and [ __ ] you know they
would sell like pakas d
like you know i love we loved it there
but then there's this also
part of it where we be getting out of
the sauna and then there's bb
these hot korean ladies with like prom
dresses
i talk about the domey girls the tomi
girls right i don't know what it is but
they were going into this whole other
area and we like what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ]
yeah so there's like stuff that uh what
is a dome what is that [ __ ] it's an
escort
oh so that there's that too that's what
it was so back in the day like
uh tommy girls used to only be korean
girls like if in k-town
you see like these russian girls a lot
of them are russian girls
they're called domi tommy girls they're
escorts right
but that's like on the low right like
yeah it's on the low so lapd don't know
i'm pretty sure they don't know i'm
pretty sure they know about it but then
they're but their escorts
dude that's what i'm saying k-town's got
like this
it's like a bubble that's hard to
infiltrate and [ __ ] for sure and like
also too like
uh escorts aren't illegal you know yeah
because that's like on like
sites and [ __ ] or yeah exactly so
escorts aren't illegal
but you know who knows what they do
after if you give them a little more
money right
kind of funny yeah escort story arizona
okay so my native american home is
strange we call him straight his name is
derek though
his rapping name was strange okay um
very educational you know he had a bunch
of native americans
he knew his history and [ __ ] worked at
the casino at night
you know and so uh i'm like
okay he's gone he i saw him put up on
his uniform
he's out so there was like um
tempe they had this uh their own like
local newspaper thing
you know in the back had uh call girls
yeah
and so i had called one up
and um showed up but didn't knock on my
door i had a sliding glass door in the
back
and knocked on it and first off
it wasn't the person that it was just
some other
white meth out lady you know that just
showed up
and so i'm like ah [ __ ] it so she came
in
and our bedrooms were upstairs it was a
janky ass apartment by the way yeah
cockroaches all that [ __ ]
walked up there and we get into my room
and she goes
okay what i need from you honey is for
you to get
naked so but i'm thinking
i mean i was so stupid obviously i'm
dumb you know i'm like
oh okay so
i got naked but the thing is the first
thing you'd ask is
aren't you supposed to get me yeah
why am i getting you why me first
it's me yeah so the next thing she said
was now honey do you have any lotion
in here i don't know oh like you handle
anything kind of low she might do are
you a little dry like yeah
you don't know i don't know i'm just i'm
under the spell yeah
and so i go yeah i think i got some in
the bathroom
yeah and so
so right when i get in the bathroom i
just heard this dude
running
it must be like a [ __ ] genetic trait
for you and your brother to get jacked
cause like your brother he got jacked in
south africa
yo
okay i guess this is i mean this is
going back to i guess
this is what i have to do i just show up
to class even though i don't know
i don't know what's going on i feel like
this is what i have to do this is what
they do
they show up to class oh i'm surprised
to get kidnapped as a kid it's so easy
oh i know i know oh that's too funny
so fast forward to like oh and this
this is the la experience now so years
later this is like probably in my 30s or
late 20s
maybe when i was working at viva maybe
early 2000 or something
obviously didn't have a girlfriend i
called the la one
and
she came over and noticed she was like
on her [ __ ] uh
her uh blackberry the whole time
and then she started saying some things
but then a red flag
the red flags start going off because
the language is similar to that one lady
that
got me in tempi
you're like wait hold on a second i've
seen this before similar language
um do you have the money and so
it was one of those things like let's
say this is the money that she's sitting
right here
my bed i didn't even have a [ __ ]
frame for it it was like
just one of those mattresses on the
ground so we're low to the ground
and then i just went i put my money here
she hadn't grabbed it yet
but then this is the major red flag she
said
okay i need to get naked
you already knew are you already so i go
wait a minute this is the same
thing i got robbed before
[Laughter]
what are these ghosts hold up let me
finish so this is the money right
i go no i don't think i want to do this
anymore you're gonna have to leave yeah
and she goes
what's the problem dear like what's why
you trip what's going on
and so i go i just i change my mind i
don't want to do this i want to go
through it
yeah so next thing you know
she has like whatever her crew chief man
whatever her manager
it's a pyramid thing yeah she gets her
on the phone and she was like
what's the matter honey now what's the
problem why are you pulling this
[ __ ] you know my girl went
over there and blah blah blah and so you
know i just you know i just
had to change mine i don't want to do it
anymore you know and so i thought
it was over and then
you've been to my place you know like
that you have to open the side gate to
get you know so
i see her exit the door but then
simultaneously i see this [ __ ] cholo
ass [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] he had his head behind his back
and he was like you got the money full
and hey i said you got the [ __ ] money
for and then i'm just like
and then so i'm like arguing in the
courtyard you know
and i'm like we didn't do anything you
know and so i'm pleading because i don't
know if this guy's got
yeah you know what i'm saying like i
don't know and then i ended up giving
him forty dollars
oh my god man why do you live you're
like
so that's the last time that has ever
had i've never done it since and that
was like
2 000. let me tell you something there's
a lot safer places you could get this
done
oh how about just jerk off you know
that's true this is
jerk off dude you don't have to go
through all that dude i don't know about
this personally
but i've heard vegas well okay this is
the reason why i know like vegas is
really good for this [ __ ] right
yeah i at so when i was doing uh the
the traveling show send foods right i
was just trying to get a regular massage
right because my back was all tight just
because we've been playing so much yeah
that's
it's understandable it's like 11 pm yeah
and so there's a few
late night massage spots that are open
and i would come in and i told tim i got
really [ __ ] pissed
because i just wanted a massage yeah
yeah and so i got i went in there and
i'm like hi
how much is massage and they're greeting
me all super nice and i'm like cool i
was like she was like okay
um are you looking for a massage i'm
like yeah
for a massage she was like yeah my back
is really tense she goes oh we don't do
that here and i'm like
what do you mean you don't do that
you're like i want a massage he goes no
it's not that type and i'm like okay
whatever i go to [ __ ] three spots
none of them would give me a regular
massage
at all but it's marketed like it's a
massage
place what are acupuncture so what my
friend told me was like yeah they'll do
massage
in the day but those girls are there for
the daytime and they do have that but
why would they want to give you an hour
massage for less money when they could
just jack you off in 10
and they make like triple the money
right so like people aren't really going
to those spots at 11 pm to get a regular
massage
they want a hand job yeah so let's just
probably just don't invite these people
to your home oh no lesson learned
lesson learned so folks uh it's not
worth it
folks don't do what i did oh [ __ ] i
learned but that's the thing with me i
gotta get hit over the head man
multiple times multiple times to where
my life is threatened
and then then i know wait a minute i
know not to do that i just pictured you
just like in that situation you throw
the money there
never never again you look just like
that moment in class we're just looking
around
your own home yeah i don't know what's
going on
that's funny hey yeah well we're gonna
wrap up all right steviebandcamp.com
i feel stir crazy um yeah get off my
band camp
i appreciate it even if it's one song at
least listen to it
if you want to buy it buy it tell a
friend hey if i give you something i
edited a
a quick little um who's how are you
editing this
dude i did it yeah um before you edit it
i i got this little small 10 second
thing that i uh
just like a preview of some of the songs
can you put it at the end of this
episode
yeah yeah that'd be no problem it's
already edited all you'd have to do is
no just give it to me oh dude thank you
thank you yeah because it it
like previews some of the songs yeah i'd
love to
that was fun bro yeah man do you think
we need to edit any of that [ __ ] no
we're good
it's good that's good we're [ __ ] good
even this part's going but we're good
we're good we're good
you can catch the jesus great podcast
every thursdays and sundays
i'll look through the front to see if i
have to delete it okay
all right and we'll see y'all next time
all right all right peace from the hip
he really couldn't predict this grip of
soul full of
words that big oh rodeo man in the west
[Music]
[Music]
he's afraid he feels portrayed live this
way could deal with shane has made
[Music]
i slipped out of her canal what you call
a sailing ship is named after a female
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
making spreads contemplating all the
news that's led what's said is